Holly Madison likely won't be commenting
on the passing of her ex Hugh Hefner the
37 year old was the Playboy founders
number one girlfriend from 2002 to 2008
the payers stopped speaking following
their split Holly was candid about her
thoughts on half with et in recent years
including their breakup she says in her
first book that he bribed her with three
million dollars to stay that situation
made me feel kind of sad for Hef because
I had told him that I was leaving and he
was like no no no they ordered another
season the show just you know state and
I finally come to a point in my life
where I realized I needed something more
genuine than he was able to give me like
I've woken up after seven years I know
you and half don't really speak much but
if you could say anything to him these
days what what would you say I wouldn't
say anything in you I think it's kind of
odd because people ask me that all the
time like do you still talk to him and
I'm like usually when people move on
they don't like talk to all their exes I
just don't think it's appropriate
Polly's tell-all book about her time in
a mansion seemingly cemented the wedge
between them well have offered me
quaaludes on the first night out and I
didn't want to take any I never did but
I saw him offer them to many girls every
night we would go out for a couple of
years and I'm actually not the first
person to have written about it or
talked about it in the media it's just
something that has been glossed over
writing this book was really about
setting myself free I hadn't spoken to
have or had anything to do with Playboy
in a number of years and I wasn't doing
it to get revenge or get a reaction or
invite him back into my life in any way
it was more about you know telling women
about my story and oh of course I have
fond memories of my time there but you
know
if we were to ask you what your best
memory of Hef was what would you say I
would say my best memory of the time at
the mansion was shooting the TV show I
think it provided us with a lot of
opportunities and you know we got to
travel because of a you know tiny thing
so we had